[Music]
welcome to a closed-off street in
downtown Atlanta I'm about to be on set
with MacGyver himself Lucas tell who
apparently is about to come out of here
getting out of a sewer right now covered
in you imagine what this is you are
disgusting but still weirdly sexy thank
you I appreciate that the rest of the
country thinks Lucas is pretty sexy too
season 1 was a consistent Friday night
ratings winner for CBS
so are you more comfortable this year
you're more like I am MacGyver
I've got that oh yeah last year was like
terrifying I'm gonna know his stuff and
now I can I can do all this Good Will
Hunting equations on the board and all
this MacGyver stuff really comfortably
and when the US government operative
isn't using his brains
he's using his brawn but when things
take two dicey they Colin visca stunt
double Mike Wilson there was actually
two of you on set today equally dirty
equally shaggy yeah he'll be doing what
eight cars go in front of me and behind
me that's Lucas stumbling and traffic
but when the cars need to get real close
Mike steps in
over the years Lucas has had some a-list
co-stars
we asked about a few Jennifer Lawrence
hilarious jealous because she's funnier
than me Miley Cyrus she's a ball of
energy swizzle yeah hard worker
yeah how about the ladies is there
anyone special in your life and like are
they coming out of the woodwork to try
to date you I actually am married to my
job right now as stupid as that sounds
it takes so much my life but this is
what celebrities say when they're
available so ladies yeah that was kind
of what I was trying to say they're
trying to say
[Music]